it's great to be joined today by John
Johnson an MIT PhD who runs an
econometrics consultancy in Washington
DC he's also co-author of every data the
misinformation hidden in the little data
you consume every day it's so great to
talk to you I think a good way to maybe
jump into this is with all of the
political polling that's going on and
questions and thoughts about can we
trust polls that don't hole cell phones
or what does the margin of error really
mean let's just start there when we see
a political poll that says Hillary +10
over Trump nationally and another that
says Trump +4 over Hillary nationally
how can the average person be sort of
moderately well equipped to look at a
poll and figure out what we can deduce
from it well it's hard and so the first
thing you have to do is you can't over
read any single poll one of the biggest
mistakes I think the media makes is
they're trying to tell stories and
narratives every day and so you get
these data points a brand new poll today
that has an interesting result suddenly
turns into an entire storyline and that
can really cause a lot of problems first
of all if you are trying to be a better
consumer of polls first thing I would
try to remind people to do is remember
what the polls are trying to suggest is
they are trying to predict the voting
patterns of what is ultimately going to
be millions of people with a hundred to
a thousand people and that's the actual
really hard statistical problem so if
the types of questions they ask are
slightly biased or suggestive in a way
that might affect the results if they
asked the wrong people any of those
things can affect the actual results so
what I always do is first I try to look
at how many people were sampled just to
see the raw numbers that's just a
helpful metric and then you often
mention the margin of error the margin
of error is just one type of bias that
we can find in polls the idea that
you're trying to predict the voting
patterns of millions of people with just
a few thousand or few hundred even what
that margin of error tells you is how
statistically confident we are that the
result the real result in other words if
you've pulled every single person how
statistically confident are the result
we got from our poll is actually close
to that so what I look at is the margin
of error how big or small that is and
then I just try to look across a range
of different polls to just sort of see
what the different numbers are looking
like ultimately there is information to
be gleaned but you just have to be very
careful and thoughtful to not over
interpret the numbers okay so let's go
through a few of these items piece by
piece and I think this will be really
interesting when you talk to pollsters
they will often give a convoluted but
seemingly well-intentioned answer about
sample size where they say once you get
beyond assuming you have the right sort
of distribution and a representative
sample that once you get beyond some
we'll say eight hundred a thousand
twelve hundred respondents that you were
not going to be better or have more
accurate results than when you if you
were to double or continue increasing
the sample size is that true and if so
how is it backed up mathematically okay
well actually it's mathematically true
with respect to only one type of error
and that's what we call sampling error
what they are right truly as a matter of
math is that if you believe you have the
sample right and you have a truly
representative sample then to eliminate
the type of error which comes from the
fact that we just can't ask every single
person that's why that or how that
margin of error gets smaller and smaller
and it is absolutely true that as you go
from a thousand to two thousand to five
thousand the decline in the margin of
error gets smaller and smaller but where
I think it's a little bit misguided and
perhaps off is that with all those other
types of errors that are really
important non-response bias
representativeness how much are the
people that you're talking to actually
representative of the broader population
with respect to those other things I
think you can get increases in accuracy
by polling more people so it kind of
plays off of a very common mistake that
people make margin of error is just
about one type of bias or err
in a sample or poll but there are many
others that actually are often far more
important and by taking or getting more
data we usually always think as
statisticians and economists the more
data the better if we can get more data
and its cost effective which is really
what it comes down to then we probably
prefer and could get better answers okay
as far as margin of error many
understand margin of error to mean the
following if we have a poll that has
Hillary Clinton polling 50% and Donald
Trump polling 45% for example if you
have a 4% margin of error that means
that although the results say Hillary
Clinton 50 she may actually be at 46 or
may actually be at 54 and that this sort
of same four-point swing would exist for
the numbers of Donald Trump is that a
useful and/or accurate understanding of
margin of error I think it's a partial
understanding let me put a little finer
point on it when we're talking about the
margin of error were truly talking about
what would happen if we repeated the
same sample or the same poll over and
over and over would we find that we
would get the actual value the actual
amount of support amongst all the voters
what we call the entire population
ninety-five out of a hundred times
that's when we talk about the 95 percent
confidence interval so it's really about
whether or not given the fact that we're
only sampling a small number of people
can we do that so yes what you are
correct when you describe it is that our
confidence of what that true whether or
not the true population the true value
as we think of it for the support for
Hillary or the support for Trump has got
to be within that range and so when we
say if we look at the lower end of the
confidence interval for Hillary and the
higher end of the confidence interval
for Trump if those two overlaps and we
usually say we can't be confident that
those two things are anything different
than a statistical tie from the pure
statistical standpoint that's the way I
like to think of it and the reality is
right now given where most of the poll
numbers are in this election we're
finding generally that we're within the
margin of error for a number of the
polls and then there are fewer it's
Stickley Hillary Clinton is ahead okay
now you mentioned at the beginning that
an individual polls importance is
smaller but that an average of polls can
be a better way to sort of interpret
poll data in terms of its predictive
value back in 2012 and I say this not to
Pat myself on the back because many many
people did this I had a 100% correct
electoral map and all I did was look at
an average of state polls and say okay
if the average in Pennsylvania is that
President Obama is ahead I'll fill that
in blue so on and so forth and many
people sort of did this is that is that
surprising to you when we look at
basically 50 individual elections in a
presidential election and can you talk
about some of the ways in that looking
at the average of polls might lead you
astray sure so first thing I would say
is that well first congratulations on
getting 50 right there the reality is
probably 38 of those were pretty much
most people could get right before
looking at any polls and it's probably
the last 12 that is really where the
differences are and that's not meant to
diminish your accomplishment I'm just
saying as a practical matter diminish
away oh I all means so that's the first
thing is that those 12 you know probably
12 stage so we always call sort of the
battleground states are usually the ones
that make a difference you raise the
very important point that we get these
national poll numbers every day Oh
nationally here's what the numbers show
but what really matters is the electoral
college and one of the other interesting
things about the whole margin of error
discussion which directly ties to this
is that a margin of error is calculated
on the total number of respondents in
the poll but let's say we cared about
voters in the state of New York and we
only had 30 New York voters in a sample
with a thousand people
well the margin of error on the New York
estimate is much much larger it's only
based on those 30 people you never hear
people or very rarely have I seen people
report that the margins of errors get
much much larger if you look at any
subgroup in a poll so national polls are
somewhat limited in their value in terms
of actually predicting electoral college
particularly when you think about the
specific states so the first thing that
I think is a really valid point is
looking closer at state polls a very
useful thing I think for Atkins
now with respect to averages I have kind
of mixed feelings on this averages can't
be powerful and when you have so many
poles there are times where looking
across the averages at least tell you
something a little bit more long-term
about trends tends to take out the sort
of extreme values and the like one of
the problem with those averages though
is that there is no margin of error
calculated ever on those poles and most
of the averages just assume all poles
are of equal quality but I can tell you
that when you actually look at the
questions that some of these polling
agencies ask there are some that are
very reputable and there are some that
are not and that's actually a really big
issue I was looking at one today from
2012 where an agency had asked
Republican voters if they were in favor
of bobbing Agrabah and 30% said yes well
Agrabah is the town from the movie 11
and they sort of had this big elaborate
joke about Oh 30 percent of Republican
voters support bombing Agrabah right
when I look back at the questions they
had eight questions all about 9/11 and
terrorist attacks right before it they
asked the same questions of Democrats
and the questions were much more limited
basically about presidential candidates
and then the question and so polling can
really you know bad poll questions still
exist so don't think that all polls are
created equal they are not and remember
those averages basically incorporate
everything into one big average number
John real quick in the limited time we
have left for our audience who wants to
look into some examples of how the same
data can be used to paint drastically
different pictures of reality do you
have some favorite examples that people
could look or research about how
representations of statistics can
reflect the data but be very very
misleading oh yeah well I actually
that's a big part of my book every data
you know I didn't write the book to sort
of be a purely political commentary in
fact many of the examples in the book
are about sort of everyday examples of
times where people have misrepresented
data either graphically with numbers and
the like and we have everything in the
book from why you shouldn't trust
representations like 4 out of 5
pediatricians prefer a certain baby food
too why why when you read a story that
says eating Greek grilled cheese will
improve your sex life you don't
necessarily want to run out and start
eating grilled cheese at least not based
on the statistics so I would point that
that's where a lot of it is I also have
launched recently in addition to my book
website I also have a blog purely on
these political issues off of Johnnie's
Johnson PhD comm and it's a good place
to find all sorts of examples where I've
been talking about all these same
polling issues we discussed today very
very important stuff for anybody who
wants to be an informed and competent
consumer of not only news but also
advertising which is where you hear so
many of these misleading statistics used
the book is every data the
misinformation hidden in the little data
you consume every day we've been
speaking with the book's co-author John
Johnson so great to talk to you thank
you great talking to you too thank you